NOW IN SESSION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBERS AND BRING IN THE
CHAMBERS AND BRING IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
MADAM CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ACOSTA AGUIAR-CURRY ALLEN
ARAMBULA BAKER [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW BLOOM [inaudible]
BONTA BROUGH [inaudible]
BURKE CABALLERO CALDERON
CARRILLO CERVANTES CHAU.
CHAVEZ CHEN.
DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU
[inaudible]
COOLEY COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DALY EGGMAN
FLORA FONG.
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GRAY.
GRAYSON HARPER HOLDEN IRWIN
JONES SAWYER.
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LIMON LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES.
CARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON QUIRK QUIRK
SILVA.
REYES RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO [inaudible]
STEINORTH STONE.
THURMOND [inaudible]
TEAM VOEPEL.
WALDRON WEBER.
WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND
FOR TODAY'S IN VOCATION.
WHICH WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR
ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN REVEREND BOB
OSHITA [inaudible]
REVEREND OSHITA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
TODAY'S BEING MARKED AS THE
SEVENTY FIFTH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
FOUR FORTY SECOND REGIMENTAL
COMBAT TEAM AND HUNDRED
BATTALION.
IN.
TWO THOUSAND ONE US ARMY
HISTORIAN ERIC SOL.
SPOKEN A LONG OVERDUE CEREMONY
IN SEATTLE.
AWARDING POSTHUMOUS MEDALS OF
HONOR PRIVATE FIRST CLASS
WILLIAM CANNOT COME LARA.
AND TECH CHRISTIAN FIFTH GRADE
JAMES WORKABLE.
I'D LIKE TO SHARE A FEW OF ERIC
SALAS WORDS [inaudible]
HE ASKED SO WHY WAS IT YOU NIECE
A SECOND GENERATION BORN IN
AMERICA WERE WILLING TO
VOLUNTEER FOR THE ARMY.
YOU WERE CONSIDERED SECOND CLASS
CITIZENS COMING FROM
CONCENTRATION CAMPS IN AMERICA.
YOUR PARENTS COULDN'T BECOME
CITIZENS OUR OWN LAND SO LAND
WAS PUT IN YOUR NAME.
BEFORE THE WAR YOU WANTED TO BE
DOCTORS LAWYERS AND
PROFESSIONALS BUT YOU COULDN'T.
NO ONE WOULD HIRE YOU.
SO YOU WORK TIME YOUR FAMILY
FARMS FLOWER ORCHARDS AND SHOPS.
YOU COULDN'T GO WHERE YOU WANTED
BEFORE YOU WANTED OR BE HOME YOU
WANTED.
FURTHERMORE YOUR PRESIDENT ON
FEBRUARY NINETEENTH.
NINETEEN FORTY TWO SIGNED AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT SAID.
YOU WEREN'T AMERICANS ANYMORE.
YOU'RE NINE ALIENS.
SO WHY DID YOU JOIN THE ARMY.
WHY DID YOU BECOME SOLDIERS AND
IRONICALLY BECOME OF ALL THINGS
THE MOST DECORATED ARMY UNIT
THAT IF THIS COUNTRY HAS EVER
PRODUCED?
YOUR OWN REGIMENTAL MODEL GO FOR
BROKE SET THE TONE FOR YOUR OWN
REGIMENT AND YOU LIVED UP TO
THIS MOTTO.
IN ONE LONG FIVE DAY BATTLE.
IN OCTOBER OF NINETEEN FORTY
FOUR TWO THOUSAND AND YOU WENT
IN TO RESCUE TWO HUNDRED TEXAS
SOLDIERS WHO COULDN'T BE RESCUED
BY THEIR OWN DIVISION.
IT WAS UNBELIEVABLE.
YOU RESCUED THE TWO HUNDRED
SOLDIERS.
OF THE TEXAS LOS BATTALION.
AT THE COST OF ALMOST ONE
THOUSAND CASUALTIES.
THE ARMY DESIGNATED THE RESCUE
OF THE LOST BATTALION. TO BE
AMONG THE TOP TEN BATTLES FOUGHT
BY THE US ARMY IN ITS TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY YEAR HISTORY.
OF THE FOURTEEN THOUSAND MEMBERS
WHO SERVE THE POOR FORTY SECOND
REGIMENTAL COMBAT TEAM.
THERE WERE EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
MEDALS OF HEROISM AND SERVICE.
YOU WOULD BECOME THE MOST
DECORATED UNION.
UNIT IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
YOU NEVER LOST FAITH IN YOUR
COUNTRY.
AND WE ARE HERE TODAY TO
CELEBRATE THAT DAY.
PRICE THAT YOU PAID.
WITH THE HIGHEST COMBAT CASUALTY
RATE OF ANY REGIMENT IS EVER
SIR.
YOU HAD THREE HUNDRED AND 14%
COMBAT CASUALTIES.
I WISH EVERY AMERICAN COULD KNOW
YOUR STORY.
WE OWE DEBT OF GREAT HONOR TO
YOU NEED FACE FOR WHAT YOU DID.
FOR THE COUNTRY AND FOR
DEMOCRACY.
IT IS A DEBT THAT CAN NEVER BE
REPAID.
AND YOUR LEGACY CONTINUES TO
PROTECT US ALL.
I REMEMBER IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINE DURING THE IRANIAN CRISIS.
THERE WAS TALK OF KEEPING
IRANIAN AMERICANS IN PROTECTIVE
CUSTODY.
SENATORS DANIEL INOUYE AND SPARK
MATSUNAGA SAID.
YOU CAN'T DO THAT.
THAT'S ALREADY BEEN DONE.
YOU'RE WRONG THEN AND YOU WOULD
BE WRONG NOW.
SO YOUR WARTIME SERVICE PROTECTS
ALL OF US.
SO WROTE US ARMY HISTORIAN
ERIC'S HOME IN.
TWO THOUSAND ONE SO IF YOU SEE
ANYBODY EIGHT VETERANS OF THE
FOUR FORTY SECOND FOUR HUNDRED
BATTALION.
ON OUR OWN THEIR NINETIES BEING
ESCORTED BY FAMILY THROUGH THE
HALLS OF THE CAPITOL TODAY.
PLEASE THANK THEM FOR THEIR
SERVICE.
THE DEBT OF GRATITUDE WE OWE TO
THOSE WHO SACRIFICES ALLOW US TO
BE HERE TODAY.
IS TRULY BEYOND WORDS.
NOW MORE ME THEM.
WITH GRATITUDE AND KINDNESS
BEYOND.
THANK YOU I INVITED HER IN
STANDING FOR TODAY'S FLAG SALUTE
WHAT WE OFFERED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN SALUTE TO OUR
FLIGHT.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
THE UNITED STATES [inaudible]
THE REPUBLIC [inaudible]
I NATION.
INDIVISIBLE.
PRETTY ADDRESSES.
YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY JUNE SEVENTH
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE ASSEMBLY MET
AT NINE A. M. ON WILL KEVIN
MULLIN SPEAKER PRO TEM ASSEMBLY
PRESIDING TEA PARTY DOTSON
WILSON AT THE MEASURE CALDERON
MOVES AND MISS WALDRON.
THE READING OF PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE THAT'S WITH
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS TO
ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
ABSENCES TODAY FOR LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER SYDNEY
CHO MONGER DOTCOM MAGADHA. FOR
PERSONAL BUSINESS ASSEMBLY BILL
GROW FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SABRINA CERVANTES AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STEVEN CHOI
ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALDERON.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS FRAZIER AND HOLDEN TO
HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON
THE FLOOR TODAY WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER THEY DEMAND SPEAKER ALSO
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT. FIVE ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS EGGMAN THURMAN TO SPEAK
[inaudible]
THE MEMORIES WITHOUT OBJECTION
SHALL BE THE ORDER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
JOINT WILL SUCCEED TO A THE FILE
NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE TO
HEAR SB.
THIRTEEN THE FIVE HUESO TODAY
UPON ADJOURNMENT SESSION IN
ROOM.
FOUR FORTY SEVEN SOME NEVER
WALDRON.
WE OPPOSE THAT MOTION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MALT WALDRON OPPOSES
THE MOTION.
WE WILL DO A ROLL CALL VOTE ON
THIS ITEM MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE [inaudible]
I MISTER CALDERON MOVES AND
MISTER BONTA MISTER GIBSON
SECONDS THAT THE RULES BE
SUSPENDED --
TO FILE NO ABA TO ALLOW THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE HERE
S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE TODAY
UPON A GERMAN IN SESSION MADAM
CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS MISTER CALDERON IS
REQUESTING.
AN AYE VOTE MISS WALDRON IS
REQUESTING A NO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
MISTER CALDERON IS REPREHENSIBLE
REQUESTING AN AYE VOTE MISS
WALDRON IS REQUESTING A NO VOTE.
MEDICAL CAN MAKE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES EYES.
FORTY SEVEN KNOWS EIGHTEEN THE
RULES ARE SUSPENDED MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SPOT SUSPEND JOIN WITH SIX YOU
GET TO A THE FILE NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE. TO HOLD AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON
THURSDAY JUNE TWENTY EIGHTH AT
EIGHT THIRTY AM.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND JOINT WILL
SUCCEED TO A THE FILE NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE PRIVACY
CONSUMER PROTECTION COMMITTEE TO
HOLD AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON
WEDNESDAY.
JUNE TWENTY SEVENTH AT ONE
THIRTY PM IN ROOM FOUR FORTY
FOUR MISS WALDRON FOR WHAT
REASON DO YOU RISE OUT WE OPPOSE
THAT MOTION. FOR ALL CALL.
THANK YOU.
WE WILL HOLD FOR MISTER CALDERON
MOVES MISTER GIBSON SECONDS THAT
THE RULES BE SUSPENDED TO ALLOW
THE PRIVACY CONSUMER PROTECTION
COMMITTEE TO HOLD INFORMAL
HEARING.
WEDNESDAY JUNE TWENTY SEVENTH.
MADAM COURT PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS BOOT DESIRE TO
VOTE MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE MISS WALDRON IS
REQUESTING A NO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE MISS WALDRON IS ASKING
FOR A NO VOTE MEDICAL CAN MAKE
CLOSE THE RULING TALLY THE
VOTES.
ICE FORTY FOUR NO EIGHTEEN THE
RULES ARE SUSPENDED. TO CALDERON
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT SUSPEND JOINT
ASSEMBLY RULES SIXTY THREE
NINETY SIX TO WITHDRAW ESPY'S
EIGHT FORTY NINE AND A FIFTY SIX
FOR THE BUDGET COMMITTEE.
AND ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER TEAM TO
TAKE THEM OUT WITHOUT REFERENCE
TO FILE FOR THE PURPOSE OF THIRD
READING.
IS WALDRON FOR WHAT REASON DO
YOU RISE WE OPPOSE THAT MOTION.
THANK YOU WE WILL TAKE A ROLL
CALL VOTE ON THIS MOTION MISTER
CALDERON MOVES A MISTER GIVES
SECOND SO THAT THE ASSEMBLY RULE
SIXTY THREE AND SIXTY NINE TO
WITHDRAW S. B. EIGHT FORTY NINE
AND EIGHT FIFTY SIX IN THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE --
IDEA TO ALLOW THE COMMITTEE TO
TAKE THEM UP WITHOUT REFERENCE
THE FILE MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE MISTER CALDERON IS
REQUESTING AN AYE VOTE MISS
WALDRON IS REQUESTING A NO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES AYE
AYES FORTY SIX KNOWS TWENTY THE
RULES ARE SUSPENDED MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MEMBERS PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO I
AM RE REFERRING ITEM FIFTEEN AB
FIFTEEN TWENTY SEVEN TO THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE. TO CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENSUS SPEND JOINT RULE SIX
TO EIGHT PHAM THOSE REQUIREMENT
TO ALLOW THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE.
DEAR AB FIFTEEN TWENTY SEVEN
JONES SAWYER ON TUESDAY JUNE
TWENTY SIXTH.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS WITH US
IN THE ASSEMBLY TODAY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA
.
SOME MEMBER BONTA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES ARE RISE IS THE CHAIR
OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS. TO RECOGNIZE
THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
CAPITAL ASSOCIATIONS SUMMER
INTERNS SEATED IN THE GALLERY.
NOW IN ITS FOURTH YEAR OF THE A
PEAK AT SUMMER INTERNSHIP
PROGRAM PROVIDES COLLEGE
STUDENTS WHO ARE DEDICATED TO
PUBLIC SERVICE A SUBSTANTIVE AND
MEANINGFUL.
WORK IN EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE
IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURE WHERE THEY CAN LEARN
ABOUT PUBLIC POLICY PART TO PAY.
IN THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
EXPAND THEIR PROFESSIONAL
NETWORKS AND POSITION THEMSELVES
FOR SUCCESSFUL PUBLIC SERVICE
CAREERS UPON GRADUATION.
WE ARE PLEASED TO HAVE THE
STUDENTS HERE AT THE CAPITOL
THROUGH AUGUST PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING THEM
.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CUNNINGHAM YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUESTS
PRODUCTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS TODAY I HAVE
THE PLEASURE OF INTRODUCING.
AN ORGANIZATION KNOWN AS THE
CALIFORNIA RANGE LAND TRUST IN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT THE RANGE
AND TRUST.
WAS FORMED AS THE ONLY RANCHER
GOVERNED STATEWIDE LAND TRUSTS
IN CALIFORNIA.
THEY BEGIN WORKING TO
PERMANENTLY PROTECT HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF ACRES.
A BRANCH RANGELAND THROUGH
AGRICULTURAL CONSERVATION
EASEMENTS AND TO DATE THEY HAVE
CONSERVED OVER THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND THANK.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING THE
RANGE RIGHT TRUST.
GIVEN A WARM ROUND OF APPLAUSE.
MISTER HOLDEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FROM THE REAR OF THE CHAMBERS
FOR YOUR GUESTS.
THEY YOU THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER.
AS CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS I WOULD
LIKE TO INTRODUCE TO NEW.
BUT PRESENT ALL THE DYNAMIC.
AND INFLUENCE SO OLIVER STONE.
HIS A MENTOR.
TEACHER MOTIVATOR BUT MOST OF
ALL A LEADER WHO HAS DEDICATED
HIS LIFE TO PUBLIC SERVICE.
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
HE HAS SERVED AS PRESIDENT CEO
OF THE CALIFORNIA BLACK CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE AND DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA BLACK CHAMBER
FOUNDATION FOR OVER TWENTY FIVE
YEARS.
HE AGGRESSIVELY LED THE
CALIFORNIA BLACK SABER IN SUCH
PUBLIC POLICY INCLUDING CO
AUTHOR IN THE NINTH CIRCUIT
INJUNCTION AGAINST.
IMPLEMENTATION OF PROPOSITION.
TWO OH NINE UNDER MISTER STONE'S
DIRECTION THE CALIFORNIA BLACK
SABER FOUNDATION BECAME THE
STATE'S ONLY AFRICAN AMERICAN
OWNED AND OPERATED LOW POWERED
RADIO STATION. NINETY SEVEN
POINT FIVE K. D. E. F. THEM
SERVING THE SACRAMENTO REGION
AND STREAMING OFF LIVE.
WORLDWIDE.
WE RECEIVE THE SACRAMENTO
OBSERVERS NEWSPAPERS LIFETIME
ACHIEVEMENT AWARD FOR BEING ONE
OF THE MOST INFLUENTIAL AFRICAN
AMERICANS IN THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO.
OVER THE PAST FORTY YEARS PLEASE
JOIN ME.
IN WELCOMING ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S
MOST INFLUENTIAL LEADERS OLIVER
STONE
.
THANK YOU MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRAZIER.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GUESTS INTRODUCTIONS.
FROM THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER
.
YES IT DOES TO THE MARIA
[inaudible]
ALSO HERE [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I RISE TODAY TO WELCOME COLONEL
JOHN KLINE.
COMMANDER OF THE SIXTIETH AIR
MOBILITY WING.
COLONEL JUSTIN NEATER.
COMMANDER OF THE EIGHT HUNDRED
TWENTY FIRST. EIGHT HUNDRED
TWENTY ONE THEN.
CONTINGENCY RESPONSE GROUP AND
COLONEL RAYMOND COSETTE
COMMANDER OF THE TH THREE
HUNDRED FORTY NINTH AIR MOBILITY
WING.
ALL FROM TRAVIS AIR FORCE BASE.
AND THEY'RE HERE.
TO HE RECOGNIZES CELEBRATE
TRAVIS AIRFORCE BASE SEVENTY
FIFTH ANNIVERSARY OF OPERATION.
THE PRIVATE JOY AT THE ELEVENTH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT TRAVIS
AIRFORCE BASE IS LOCATED IN
SOLANO COUNTY.
AND IS KNOWN AS AMERICA'S FIRST
CHOICE.
AND AS THE GATEWAY TO THE
PACIFIC.
THE BASS ERECTED LESS THAN SIX
MONTHS AFTER THE ATTACK ON PEARL
HARBOR.
WAS ORIGINALLY NAMED THE
FAIRFIELD SO SOON ARMY AIR BASE.
AND HAD VERY FEW [inaudible]
A REMARKABLE [inaudible]
BEGINNINGS.
THIS IS LOCATED ON THE WINDS UP
HILLS OF SOLANO COUNTY IT WAS A
SOLITARY AIR SCRIPT.
WITH JUST A FEW TAR PAPER SHACKS
TO HEALTHIER WITH.
THE BASIS PERSONNEL HAVE BEEN
PROBABLY SERVING OUR COUNTRY
EVER SINCE.
PROVIDING VITAL INTO VERSUS
SERVICES AND NOTABLY MEDICAL
SUPPORT.
AIRLIFT SERVICE AND AERIAL
REFUELING.
ALL IN SUPPORT OF U. S.
ENGAGEMENT IN OVERSEAS CONFLICTS
AND EMERGENCIES.
TRAVIS IS AMERICA'S FIRST CHOICE
ESPECIALLY IN PROVIDING
HUMANITARIAN SERVICES IN THE U.
S. AND AROUND THE WORLD.
TRAVIS DISPATCH AIRCRAFT THAT
BROUGHT VIETNAMESE REFUGEES TO
THE U. S. IN THE AFTERMATH OF
THE FALL OF SAIGON.
IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE TRAVIS
AIRLIFTED VITAL RELIEF SUPPLIES
AND PERSONNEL TO SANTA CLARA
COUNTY AFTER THE OCTOBER
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE LOMA PRIETA
EARTHQUAKE.
TRAVIS AIRLIFTED PERSONNEL AND
TWELVE TONS OF EQUIPMENT TO
GROUND.
ZERO AND THE PENTAGON IN
RESPONSE TO THE SEPTEMBER
ELEVENTH TWO THOUSAND ONE
TERRORIST ATTACKS.
AND MUCH MUCH MORE.
SINCE ITS FOUNDING TRAVIS IS
ALSO HAD A MAJOR AN EXTREMELY
BENEFICIAL IMPACT ON THE REGION.
WITH MORE THAN FOURTEEN THOUSAND
MILITARY MEMBERS AND CIVILIAN
EMPLOYEES THE BASE ANNUALLY
CONTRIBUTES OVER ONE POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS TO THE REGION.
COLLEAGUES CURRENT CLIENT ASKED
ME TO EXTEND TRAVIS AIRFORCE
BASE SINCERE APPRECIATION FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SUPPORT
OVER THE YEARS.
COLONEL IT'S BEEN A PRIVILEGE
AND AN HONOR. TO WORK WITH YOU.
AS IT IS MY TIME TO THE
ASSEMBLY.
COLLEAGUES PLEASE ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGES THE AIRMEN AND
WOMEN UP THERE IN THE GALLERY
WHO ACCOMPANY THE COLONEL'S. TO
BE HERE TODAY.
SERVICE RECOGNITION.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN CONGRATULATING
TRAFFIC TRAVIS AIR FORCE BASE ON
THE CAGE OF ITS SEVENTY FIFTH
ANNIVERSARY AND JOIN ME
COMMENDING THE PACE AND ALL OF
ITS PERSONNEL. FOR THEIR
EXEMPLARY RECORD OF IN INSURING
THE SECURITY OF THE UNITED
STATES.
PROVIDING HUMANITARIAN RELIEF
AND CONTRIBUTING TO THE ECONOMY
OF OUR REGION [inaudible]
THANK YOU
[inaudible]
REALLY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AS A
VICE CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
LATINO LEGISLATIVE [inaudible]
CAUCUS AGAIN GREAT ON WELCOME
THE WHEN THE TEAM CALIFORNIA LET
ME KNOW CAPITAL ASSOCIATION
FOUNDATION SUMMER INTERN.
THIS ANNUAL INTERNSHIP PROGRAM
WHICH BEGINS TODAY AND ENDS
AUGUST THIRD PLACES TEN HIGH
SCHOOL JUNIORS AND SENIORS IN
OFFICES THROUGHOUT SACRAMENTO
WHERE THEY EXPLORED LEGISLATION.
LEARN ABOUT PUBLIC SERVICE AND
DEVELOP PROFESSIONALS BILLS TO
AID THEM IN COLLEGE AND BEYOND.
THE PROGRAM PRICE ITSELF ON
PROVIDING STUDENTS FROM
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES A CHANCE
IN A MEANINGFUL PROFESSIONAL
EXPERIENCE IN PUBLIC SERVICE.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING THIS YEAR'S CLASS TO
THE STATE CAPITOL.
MEMBERS THERE WILL BE A
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS BEGINNING
IMMEDIATELY IN THE MEMBERS LACK
[inaudible]
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS.
BEGINNING IMMEDIATELY THE
MEMBERS LOUNGE IS RECESSED A
CREDIT CAUCUS MEMBERS. TO THE
MEMBERS LOUNGE
WE ARE BACK IN
SESSION.
PLEASE COME TO THE FLOOR.
SO WE MAY RESUME.
THE BUSINESS BEFORE THE HOUSE
.
MEMBERS WE ARE BACK IN SESSION.
PLEASE RETURN OF THE FLOOR IF
YOU HAVEN'T DONE SO ALREADY.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IS
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO RE REFER THE FOLLOWING BILLS
COMMITTEE.
SB SIXTY SIX WIECKOWSKI FROM THE
REVENUE TAXATION COMMITTEE TO
THE RULES COMMITTEE.
S. B. FIVE FIFTY ONE HUESO FROM
THE BANKING FINANCE COMMITTEE TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT REQUEST
IS GRANTED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY SIX
IN JOINT RULE SIXTY TWO A THE
FILE NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW
THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO HEAR
S. B. TWO TWENTY SEVEN DE LEóN.
ON WEDNESDAY JUNE TWENTY SEVENTH
PENDING REFERRAL REFERRAL TO THE
REFERRAL FROM THE REVENUE TAX
ISSUE COMMITTEE.
ALSO WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT
REQUEST IS GRANTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
TAKE A BUSINESS.
WE'RE GONNA BE TAKING UP.
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE THIS
IS S. B.. EIGHT FORTY NINE S. B.
[inaudible]
EIGHT FORTY NINE A CORPORATION.
SENATE WILL EAT FORTY NINE BY
THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW AND ACTUALLY IN
THE MEDI CAL MAKING PREPARATIONS
THERE FOR TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET.
MR TANG YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER S. B.
EIGHT FOUR NINE HAS PROVISIONS
RELATED TO THE BUDGET PACKAGE
THAT IMPLEMENT THE PROP. SIX A
BUDGET PACKAGE NOW BECAUSE THIS
BILL AMENDS MEASURES THAT WERE
ADOPTED BY THE VOTERS IT DOES
REQUIRE A TWO THIRDS VOTE.
BUT THE BILL CREATES THE
PHYSICIAN DENTIST LOAN REPAYMENT
PROGRAM FOR PROVIDERS THAT SERVE
LOW INCOME FAMILIES.
ON MEDI CAL THE PROGRAM WILL BE
FUNDED WITH PROP FIFTY SIX
FUNDING THAT WE ARE ADDING TO
THE BUDGET.
ESTABLISHES A NEW DENTAL
INTEGRATION PILOT PROGRAM IN SAN
MATEO COUNTY IN NO COST PILOT
THAT THE COUNTY HOPES WILL
EXPAND.
DENTAL ACCESS.
INCREASES THE AMOUNT OF THE
QUALITY ASSURANCE FEE REVENUE
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES CAN USE FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS BY.
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND THE
DEPARTMENT CAN SHOW THAT THERE
COSTS TO THE RUN OF THE PROGRAM
ARE HIGHER THAN THE LEVEL
ALLOWED BY THE MEASURE.
WITHOUT RESPECT AS FOR I DON'T.
THEY WISH TING MISTER OBERNOLTE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT FORTY
NINE THIS TRAILER BILL WILL
ESTABLISH AN EDUCATIONAL LOAN
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM FOR
QUALIFYING DENTIST.
AND PHYSICIANS AND THIS PROGRAM
SHOULD HELP INSURE ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE AND UNDERSERVED
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA HOWEVER WHEN
WE'RE HAVING THIS DISCUSSION I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE WILL NEVER.
SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
OF ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE AND
UNDERSERVED PARTS OF CALIFORNIA
UNTIL WE ARE WILLING. TO RAISE
THE REIMBURSEMENT RATE FOR MEDI
CAL PROVIDERS TO THE POINT WHERE
IT IS POSSIBLE FOR A PHYSICIAN
OR A DENTIST TO HAVE A PRACTICE
IN RURAL CALIFORNIA.
AND SERVE THE MEDICAL POPULATION
WHILE STAYING IN BUSINESS.
UNTIL WE ARE WILLING TO TAKE
THAT STEP WE ARE NEVER GOING TO
COMPLETELY SOLVE THIS PROBLEM
HOWEVER THIS PROGRAM IS A FIRST
STEP.
AND IT'S A GOOD ONE AYE URGENT
AYE VOTE.
A RICH OVERNIGHT HE MISS
WALDRON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL --
MY BROTHER WENT THROUGH SUCH A
PROGRAM IN NEW YORK YEARS AGO.
BEING ABLE TO HAVE PROVIDERS
ESPECIALLY IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES IS ESSENTIAL WE KNOW
THAT WE ARE LACKING PROVIDERS UP
AND DOWN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I'M EXCITED ABOUT THE DENTAL CAL
PORTION IT'S A WAY TO LOOK AT TO
SEE HOW THE UTILIZATION RATES
WILL INCREASE IF WE CAN ACTUALLY
--
INCENTIVIZE PROVIDERS TO LOCATE
IN AND STAY IN CALIFORNIA AND
ALSO ACCEPTED THE CALL SAWYER
CHEN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON SEEING.
NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION [inaudible]
RETAIN.
WITH THAT CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
ZARA VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SEVENTY
TWO KNOWS.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WITHOUT REFERENCE
REFERENCE TO FILE MEAN WE'RE
GOING TO BE TAKING UP.
S. B. EIGHT FIFTY SIX CORKERY.
SENATE BILL EIGHT FIFTY SIX BY
THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW AND ACTUALLY TO
THE STATE BUDGET MAKING
APPROPRIATIONS THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL REALLY
TO THE BUDGET.
THE SHOOTING YOU MAKE AN OPEN I
THINK YOU WOULD SPEAKER S. B. A
FIFTY SIX OF THE COMPANION
MEASURE TO S. B. EIGHT FOUR NINE
WHICH WE JUST.
PASSED THAT ALSO MAN'S THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT WHICH
WAS SB EIGHT FORTY WHICH WAS
PASSED ON JUNE FOURTEENTH.
THE BILL ADDS THREE BILLION
DOLLARS OF SPECIAL FUNDS IN
FEDERAL FUNDS TO THE BUDGET ACT.
WITHIN THAT IS ONE BILLION
DOLLARS FOR PROP FIFTY SIX
EXPENDITURES WHICH WE JUST
DISCUSSED. FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
OF THAT IS FOR THIS POSITION
PROVIDERS THE BILL MENTAL
PAYMENTS BY TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY MILLION FROM LOAN
REPAYMENT ACT FOR QUALIFYING.
RECENT GRADUATES EFFICIENT A
DENTIST TO SERVE MEDI CAL
BENEFICIARIES.
AND ALSO EXPANDS ONE POINT FOUR
BILLION F. CAP AND TRADE
EXPENDITURES. TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTEEN MILLION DOLLARS OF
OTHER SPECIAL FUNDS TO FIGHT
POLLUTION.
THE MAJOR PROVISIONS INCLUDE
THREE ENTERED A FIVE MILLION TO
INVEST IN THE AIR QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT ACTIVITIES.
THAT IMPLEMENT ALL ACTED THAT
IMPLEMENT A. B..
SIX ONE SEVEN ALSO MONEY FOR
CLEAN VEHICLES IMPORTS OF ALMOST
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
A TWO HUNDRED FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR VARIOUS PROGRAMS FOR
TO IMPROVING THE HEALTH OF OUR
FORCE.
IN REDUCING FIRE RISKS THREE
HUNDRED AND FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
FOR INVESTMENTS IN AGRICULTURE.
OUR IT ALSO IN ADDITION I WOULD
LIKE TO POINT OUT IT DOES
INCLUDE SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
FOR ADDITIONAL D. M. V. STOPPING
I KNOW.
MANY OF OUR DISTRICTS HAVE BEEN
HEARING ABOUT LONG DMV LINE SO
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
PUTTING IN.
HE IMMEDIATELY TO HELP MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE CAN GET INTO DMV AND
OUT OF DMB WITHOUT HAVING TO
WAIT HOURS.
I WOULD THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIGHT.
THE ENGLISH TEN MISTER OBERNOLTE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS
TRAILER BILL IMPLEMENTS THE
EXPENDITURE PLAN FOR CAP AND
TRADE REVENUES.
STATE LAW REQUIRES US TO SPEND
THESE REVENUES ON REDUCTION OF
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND I
THINK AS GOOD STEWARDS OF THAT'S
TAXPAYER MONEY WE ARE OBLIGATED
TO SPEND IT IN THE MOST
EFFICIENT WAY THAT WE POSSIBLY
CAN.
FORTUNATELY FOR US EFFICIENCY IS
VERY EASY TO MEASURE WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTIONS IF YOUR LOOKING AT A
PROGRAM YOU TAKE THE TOTAL COST
OF THE PROGRAM.
IN DOLLARS AND YOU DIVIDE BY THE
NUMBER OF TONS OF CARBON THAT
THAT PROGRAM REDUCES.
AND THAT GIVES YOU THE COST OF
REDUCING EACH TON OF CARBON.
SO THOUGH THE LOWER THE COST OF
REDUCTION THE HIGHER THE
EFFICIENCY OF THE PROGRAM SO
JUST FOR COMPARISON SOME OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE FUNDED IN THIS
TRAILER BILL ARE VERY EFFICIENT
THINGS LIKE.
HEALTHY FORESTS DAIRY DIE
GESTURES ORGANIC RECYCLING.
COST PER TON OF CARBON REDUCED
FOR THOSE PROGRAMS IS UNDER TEN
DOLLARS PER TON.
HOWEVER THERE ARE OME VERY
INEFFICIENT USES OF THE MONEY
CONTAINED IN THIS TRAILER BILL
FOR EXAMPLE THE CLEAN VEHICLE
REBATE PROGRAM THAT'S ACOSTA
OVER FORTY SIX DOLLARS PER TON
OF CARBON REDUCED IN OTHER
WORDS.
THAT'S FOUR TIMES LESS
EFFICIENT.
I IN THEIR PROGRAMS LIKE THE
CLEAN TRUCK AND BUS BELCHER
INCENTIVE PROGRAM THAT HAVE A
COST OF OVER FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DOLLARS PER TON OF CARBON.
SO THAT'S OVER FORTY TIMES LESS
EFFICIENT THAN THE MOST
EFFICIENT USES IN THIS BILL.
I TO PUT IT A DIFFERENT WAY
MEMBERS WE COULD BE DOING A LOT
BETTER JOB AT REDUCING CARBON WE
COULD REDUCE MANY MORE TONS OF
CARBON DIOXIDE THAN WE DO IN
THIS TRAILER BILL.
AND FOR THIS REASON I FEEL IT
MUST BE OPPOSED ARJUN OVER.
MISTER GRAYSON HERE RECOMMENDS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB.
EIGHT FIFTY SIX THIS APRIL OVER
FIFTY MEMBERS FROM BOTH HOUSES
SIGNED A LETTER WHICH CALLED ON
THE GOVERNOR TO FUND COMMUNITY
AIR MONITORING PROGRAMS.
ESTABLISHED LAST YEAR BY AB SIX
SEVENTEEN I AM PROUD TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT THIS BILL
INCLUDES FIFTY MILLION FOR
QUALITY MONITORING THIS YEAR FOR
AIR QUALITY MONITORING THIS
YEAR.
WITH A COMMITMENT FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING NEXT YEAR. FOR
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE IN CLOSE
PROXIMITY TO BOTH STATIONARY AND
MOBILE SOURCES OF CRITERIA
POLLUTANTS THIS FUNDING IS A
VITAL FIRST STEP IN ADDRESSING
ONGOING DISPARITIES IN HEALTH
AND WELLNESS.
I WANT TO THANK MY COAUTHOR FROM
COACHELLA THE CHAIRS OF THE
BUDGET COMMITTEES AND
PARTICULARLY MISTER SPEAKER FOR
HIS STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
EFFORT.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHERE I'VE.
THANK YOU MISS GRAYSON SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
MISTER TAINE YOU MAY CLOSE WE
WISH THANK MADE SPEAKER JUST IN
REGARDS TO THE AYE AYE CAPTAIN
TRADE BUDGET --
AS WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO MAKE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS IN REDUCING
OUR GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
THERE ARE AREAS WE HAVEN'T MADE
AS MUCH PROGRESS ONE OF THOSE
AREAS WHERE IS WITH REGARDS TO
TRANSPORTATION.
TRANSPORTATION IS APPROXIMATELY
40% OF OUR GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS A PASSENGER VEHICLES A
PARTICULAR ABOUT 80% OF THAT
40%.
OF THESE ARE AREAS WHERE WE
HAVEN'T MADE AS MUCH PROGRESS
WHERE WE STILL NEED TO CONTINUE
TO PUSH THE ENVELOPE AND TRY TO
MOVE TOWARD.
CLEANER AIR.
IS WHY WE DO CONTINUE TO FUND
THOSE PROGRAMS IN THIS BUDGET.
I WOULD THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
DR.
THANK YOU MISTER TANK.
AND WITH THAT CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY THAT EYES
FIFTY SIX KNOWS FIFTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES [inaudible]
AND WE WE WILL HAVE IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL TO THE SENATE ON SB
EIGHT FIFTY SIX AS WELL LAUGHS.
S. B. EIGHT FORTY NINE WHICH WE
PREVIOUSLY [inaudible]
ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE AWAITING A BUDGET
BILL FROM THE SENATE.
SO IN THE MEANTIME WE ARE GOING.
TAKE UP SOME ITEMS.
IT WAS AS GO AHEAD DO SECOND
READING COOPERATE.
SENATE BILL 1-084-519-9406
TWELVE TO NINE TWENTY FOUR WITH
AMENDMENTS EIGHT TWENTY ONE OF
MOMENTS FIVE THIRTY ONE FIVE
SIXTY ONE WITH AMENDMENTS
913-142-8820 TWO WITH AMENDMENTS
TEN OH SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS AND
TEN THIRTEEN WITH AMENDMENTS.
OR BILLS WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING.
TO PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEMS.
FOURTEEN AND FIFTEEN FILE ITEMS
NINETEEN TWENTY AND TWENTY ONE
WILL BE CONTINUED.
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
THIRD READING FILE.
GOING TO PASS A RETAIN ON FILE
ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY TWO GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
[inaudible] TWENTY THREE I
BELIEVE MR KILEY AYE IS READY
THIS IS FILE ITEM. TWENTY PARMI.
TWENTY FOUR A C. R. TO FIFTEEN
BY MISTER KILEY THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO FIFTEEN BY SOME REMEMBER
KILEY RELATIVE TO THE TWENTY
THREE ASILOMAR A AYE PRINCIPLES.
MISTER KILEY EMAIL OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
TODAY I PRESENT ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION.
TO FIFTEEN THROUGH WHICH ARE
LEGISLATURE CAN EXPRESS ITS
SUPPORT FOR THE ASILOMAR
PRINCIPLES AS GUIDING VALUES FOR
THE VELDT DEVELOPMENT OF
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE.
IN JUST THE LAST FEW YEARS THE
CAPABILITY OF ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE HAS REACH
MILESTONES THAT SOME PREDICTED
WERE EITHER UNACHIEVABLE OR
STILL DECADES AWAY.
PROVIDING A GLIMPSE OF THE
UNBOUNDED POTENTIAL FOR
ECONOMIC.
AND SOCIAL IMPACT.
IN MARCH OF TWENTY SIXTEEN
GOOGLE DEEP MINES ALFA GO BEAT
THE WORLD'S REIGNING GO
CHAMPION.
USING TACTICS THAT EXCEEDED AND
SOPHISTICATION AND ELEGANCE
STRATEGIES DEVELOPED OVER TWO
MILLENNIA.
OF HUMAN EXPERIENCE.
IN NOVEMBER OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
TESLA ANNOUNCED THAT ITS
VEHICLES HAD COLLECTIVELY DRIVEN
OVER THREE HUNDRED MILLION MILES
USING AUTONOMOUS STEERING IN
NAVIGATION.
SURPASSING BY UP 240% THE SAFETY
RECORD.
OF HUMAN DRIVERS.
I JUST LAST MONTH GOOGLE
UNVEILED A NEW TYPE OF A AYE
ASSISTANCE.
WOULD USES LANGUAGE
INDISTINGUISHABLE FROM THAT OF A
NATIVE SPEAKER TO MAKE
RESERVATIONS BOOK FLIGHTS AND
SCHEDULE MEETINGS OVER THE
PHONE.
NOW THIS IS JUST THE BEGINNING.
OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE IS
POISED TO DISRUPT DOMAINS
INCLUDE HEALTHCARE.
LAW FINANCE MANUFACTURING
EDUCATION EVEN GOVERNMENT.
IN EACH AREA A AYE CARRIES THE
POTENTIAL TO DRAMATICALLY
IMPROVE.
ECONOMIC PROSPERITY AND HUMAN
WELL BEING.
SO LONG AS IT IS DEVELOPED IN A
MANNER THAT ENSURE SECURITY
RELIABILITY AND CONSONANTS
[inaudible]
HUMAN VALUES.
THE PURPOSE OF TODAY'S
RESOLUTION.
IS TO IDENTIFY A SET OF SHARED
VALUES THE CAN UNDERPIN
COOPERATION BETWEEN POLICYMAKERS
A AYE RESEARCHERS AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS.
AS WE WORK TOGETHER TO REALIZE
THE PAST POSITIVE POTENTIAL OF
ARTIFICIAL [inaudible]
INTELLIGENCE.
THE ASILOMAR PRINCIPLES ALL
TWENTY THREE OF WHICH ARE SET
FORTH IN TODAY'S RESOLUTION.
WE'RE DEVELOP HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THEY GET THEIR NAME FROM THE
CONVENTION SITE NEAR PACIFIC
GROVE.
WE'RE IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THE WORLD'S LEADING A
AYE RESEARCHERS ECONOMISTS LEGAL
SCHOLARS AND PHILOSOPHERS MET TO
DISCUSS HOW BEST TO ENSURE A
EYES DEVELOPS A PLEA.
AND THAT THE COURT.
THE PRINCIPLES ADOPTED AT THE IS
STILL OUT OF CELLMARK STRESSED
THE NEED FOR SAFETY.
TRANSPARENCY PRIVACY AND
ALIGNMENT WITH HUMAN VALUES.
NOTABLY ONE OF THE PRINCIPLES
PROVIDES THAT THERE SHOULD BE
CONSTRUCTIVE AND HEALTHY
EXCHANGE BETWEEN A AYE
RESEARCHERS.
AND POLICY MAKERS.
ANOTHER STATES A THE APPLICATION
OF A I THE PERSONAL DATA MUST
NOT UNREASONABLY CURTAIL
PEOPLE'S REAL OR PERCEIVED
LOVER.
AT ANOTHER SETS FORTH THE POWER
CONFERRED BY CONTROL OF HIGHLY
ADVANCED A AYE SYSTEMS SHOULD
RESPECT AND IMPROVE RATHER THAN
SUBVERTS.
THE SOCIAL AND CIVIC PROCESSES
AND WHICH THE HEALTH OF SOCIETY
DEPENDS.
THE ASYLUM ARE PRINCIPLES HAVE
BEEN INDEPENDENTLY ENDORSED BY
MORE THAN TWELVE HUNDRED LEADING
EXPERTS IN THE FIELD OF A AYE.
INCLUDING THE LATE STEPHEN
HAWKING YOU ONE MOSQUE AND
DENNIS ASADA'S FOUNDER OF DEEP
MIGHT.
THE RESOLUTION IS SPONSORED BY
THE FUTURE OF LIFE INSTITUTE AN
ORGANIZATION FOUNDED BY MIT
PROFESSOR MAX TEGMARK AND UC
SANTA CRUZ PROFESSOR ANTHONY
AGUIRRE.
IT'S COMMITTED A AYE SAFETY
RESEARCH AND THE DEVELOPMENT OF
BENEFICIAL A AYE.
BY ENDORSING THESE PRINCIPLES
TODAY WILL JOIN IN THE
RECOGNITION OF SHARED VALUES
THAT CAN BE APPLIED TO RESEARCH
DEVELOPMENT AND LONG TERM
PLANNING.
HELPING TO REINFORCE
CALIFORNIA'S COMPETITIVE EDGE IN
THE FIELD OF ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE WILL ASSURING THAT
IT'S BENEFITS ARE MANIFOLD AND
WIDESPREAD.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND THAT'S THE FIRST WILL
BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISS KILEY MISTER
CALDERON.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY --
REYES ARISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
IS IS SOMETHING THAT WE
ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO TAKE VERY
SERIOUSLY IN THIS.
ON THE IN THIS BODY ARE THERE
ARE DIFFERENT TYPES OF
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE OP
COATED ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
WHERE YOU GIVE A COMMAND.
AYE AND IT'S COATED TO GIVE YOU
A CERTAIN TYPE OF RESPONSE AND
THEN THERE'S A TON OF THIS
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE THAT
ACTS ON ITS OWN AND RIGHT NOW
THERE ARE COMPANIES THAT ARE.
REALLY STRIVING TO BE THE LEADER
IN ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE WHAT
THAT MEANS IS IS THAT THERE ARE
NO BREAKS ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE ISN'T SOMETHING
THAT THERE'S JUST AN ON OFF
SWITCH.
YOU LITERALLY AS A COMPANY COULD
UNLEASH ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
INTO OUR NETWORK AND ONCE IT'S
GONE YOU CANNOT STOP IT ONCE
IT'S THERE YOU CANNOT STOP IT
FROM GOING ANYWHERE IN DOING
ANYTHING.
AND SO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT THE LEGISLATURE RECOGNIZE
THESE PRINCIPLES AND ADOPT THESE
PRINCIPLES BUT ALSO TAKES IS
REALLY SERIOUS LOOK OUT
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE.
AND WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO TO
REGULATE THAT FEEL UP BECAUSE AT
SOME POINT IN ENTERPRISING
COMPANY AN ENTERPRISING
INDIVIDUAL COULD ONLY SOMETHING%
THAT WE CANNOT STOP WE CAN NEVER
TAKE BACK I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT THIS LEGISLATURE
TAKE THIS ISSUE.
EXTREMELY SERIOUSLY AND WE HAVE
A LOT OF REALLY CAPABLE AND ABLE
MEMBERS THAT ARE ABLE TO WORK ON
THIS ISSUE AND COME UP WITH SOME
TYPE OF POLICY THAT NOT ONLY
WORKS FOR CALIFORNIA BUT SERVES
AS AN INTERNATIONAL MODEL A
NATIONAL AND INTERNATIONAL
MODEL.
FOR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO FOLLOW
AS WELL AS OTHER NATIONS AND SO
I'M GLAD THAT MY COLLEAGUE RAISE
THIS ISSUE AND BROUGHT THESE
PRINCIPLES TO THE LEGISLATURE'S
THAT WE COULD TAKE A VOTE ON IT
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION DEBATE
MUCH KILEY YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU
WISH I ASKED THE FIRST WILL BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
THINGS KILEY FIRST ROLE WILL BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION CARPOOL OF MONROE.
AMBITIOUS IS FOR CO AUTHORS CO
AUTHORS AND ACR TO FIFTEEN THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS [inaudible]
CO AUTHORS [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE THERE SEVENTY THREE
CO AUTHORS AT A WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED [inaudible]
FILE ITEMS. TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
SIX AND TWENTY SEVEN PASS AND
RETAIN.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT A CHE ARE.
THIRTY FOUR BY MISTER EDUARDO
GARCIA OF THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION THIRTY
FOUR BY SOME THE MEMBER EDUARDO
GARCIA AND OTHERS RELATIVE
AGRICULTURAL LABOR SHORTAGES.
MR GARCIA.
THINGS SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
THIS MAY BE AN ISSUE THAT --
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE CANNOT
ADDRESS.
AGRICULTURE IS THE KEY
CALIFORNIA INDUSTRY THAT EMPLOYS
MORE THAN EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
FARMWORKERS ACCORDING TO A TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN UC DAVIS STUDY
WITH CALIFORNIA.
ET DE.
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE ESTIMATES
CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURE OUTPUT
INCLUDES MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED
COMMODITIES.
GOING TO THE NATIONAL
AGRICULTURAL SURVEY OVER 60% OF
FARMWORKERS ARE UNAUTHORIZED AND
VARIOUS SOURCES ESTIMATE THAT.
THAT NUMBER COULD BE CLOSER
275%.
IT DOES NOT AUTHORIZE WORKERS
WERE TO BE DEPORTED IT COULD
RESULT IN THE NATIONAL.
WHITE FOOD SHORTAGE CRISIS WELL
I BELIEVE THAT THE STATE SHOULD
HAVE THE RIGHT TO ADDRESS OUR
OWN LABOR ISSUES.
THE US CONSTITUTION MAKES IT
EXPLICITLY CLEAR.
THAT IMMIGRATION ISSUES ARE
UNDER THE JURISDICTION OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
TODAY'S FARMWORKERS ARE AGING.
AND THEIR CHILDREN DON'T WANT TO
DO THIS WORK.
MEANWHILE THERE ARE FEWER
IMMIGRANTS COMING TO THE COUNTRY
TO REPLACE.
THOSE INDIVIDUALS DOING THESE
JOBS.
THIS RESOLUTION WOULD PUT THE
ISSUE OF LABOR SHORTAGES ON THE
RADAR.
OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
WOULD URGE CONGRESS TO ALLOW
STATES TO ADDRESS THEIR OWN
LABOR ISSUES MEMBERS.
I THINK GOD THIS IS AN ISSUE
THAT IS VERY DIFFICULT TO
DIVORCE.
FROM THE CURRENT NATIONAL
CONVERSATION HAPPENING IN
WASHINGTON DC AS A RACE A
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM.
AND CERTAINLY --
IMPOSSIBLE TO DIVORCE FROM THE
CURRENT SITUATION AT THE BORDER.
AS CALIFORNIA DEPENDS HEAVILY ON
AGRICULTURE ECONOMY.
AND MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE A
STABLE WORKFORCE.
I THINK NOW MORE THAN EVER WE
OUGHT TO WEIGH IN HEAVILY.
WHEN IT COMES TO THIS ISSUE THAT
AGAIN CAN PRESENT IN NATIONAL
FOOD CRISIS FOR THIS COUNTRY AND
CERTAINLY FOR OUR STATE?
THAT'S WHY I PRESENT TO YOU AJ
ARE THIRTY FOUR AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER GARCIA.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
IT'S AN AJ ARE REQUIRES A ROLL
CALL VOTE MISTER GARCIA DID YOU
WANT CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THERE'S A FIRST ROLL THE FOR CO
AUTHORS CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
[inaudible]
HOW AUTHORS AJ ARE FOR THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS MEMBERS?
IT'S CO AUTHORS [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND WE HAVE FIFTY
SIX COAUTHORS ADDED.
WE WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON THE
RESOLUTION THIS IS A ROLL CALL
VOTE ON AJ ARE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLL-ON.
WELL MEMBERS WOULD WISH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHICH TO GO
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ON TYLER I FIFTY SEVEN NO
ZERO THAT RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
CONTINUINGON THE THIRD READING
FILE WHILE WE WAIT FOR THE
SENATE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX SJR
[inaudible]
SIX EIGHTEEN CORKERY.
SENATE RESOLUTION SIXTEEN BY
CENTER WELCOME OTHERS RELATIVE
TO FEDERAL TEMPORARY PROTECTED
STATUS.
MR LIKELY FEMALE.
WE'LL THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
BURRS REPRESENTING SJR. SIXTEEN
NUMBING UP CENTERS WILK AND
CENTER [inaudible]
HUESO.
CALLING ON THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO EXTEND THE
TEMPORARY PROTECTED STATUS ALSO
KNOWN AS TPS. FOR RESIDENTS FROM
THE COUNTRIES OF EL SALVADOR
HAITI.
HONDURAS NICARAGUA IN THE SUDAN.
I AM PROUD TO REPRESENT A
DISTRICT WITH THE SALVADORAN
POPULATION.
LAST NOVEMBER I MET WITH THE
GROUP OF SALVADORANS FROM MY
DISTRICT REGARDING THE PENDING
EXPIRATION.
OF THE TEMPORARY PROTECTED
STATUS PROGRAM.
THEIR STORIES WERE TRULY MOVING.
IN MAY WHEN IT WAS ANNOUNCED
THAT TPS WOULD NOT BE RENEWED.
LIKE SO MANY TPS HOLDERS MY
CONSTITUENTS WERE DEVASTATED TO
LEARN.
THE TPS HAD BEEN CANCELED.
THEY'RE FRIGHTENED AT THE
PROSPECT OF BEING SEPARATED FROM
THEIR CHILDREN WHO ARE AMERICAN
CITIZENS AGE TWENTY AND TWENTY
SIX THEIR CHILDREN ARE WORKING
AND CAREERS AND ATTENDING
COLLEGE RESPECTIVELY.
THE SEPTEMBER TWENTY NINETEEN
DEADLINE TO LOSE TPS STATUS IS
COMING UP SOON THRILLED
SALVADORANS.
A LITTLE OVER A YEAR IS NOT
ENOUGH TIME FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS TO COMPLETELY CHANGE
THEIR LIVES.
IF THEY RETURNED EL SALVADOR
THEY WOULD HAVE NO PLACE TO
LIVE.
JOBS TO EARN A LIVING
[inaudible]
BUT MOST.
MOST OF ALL.
THEY FOR THE VIOLENCE IN GANGS
OF POLITICAL UNREST.
HAVING FAMILY MEMBERS WHO SERVED
IN THE MILITARY THEY FEAR FOR
THEIR VERY LIVES IF THEY'RE
FORCED TO RETURN.
TPS HOLDERS OF ALREADY FULFILLED
MANY OF THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
LAWFUL PERMANENT RESIDENTS.
EVERY DAY THE DEMONSTRATE THEY
BECOME FULL MEMBERS OF SOCIETY
THROUGH EMPLOYMENT.
HOMEOWNERSHIP AND THE RAISING OF
STORY OF MY CONSTITUENT
ILLUSTRATED.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SHOULD
EXTEND TPS REAL SALVADOR HAITI
HONDURAS NICARAGUA AND SUDAN
WHILE ALSO WORKING TOWARD A
PERMANENT SOLUTION. FOR
RESIDENCY FOR EACH OF THEM.
THIS BIPARTISAN RESOLUTION IS
COMMITTED TO OUR SHARED VALUES
OF JUSTICE AND FAIRNESS.
PROTECTING OUR TPS OLDER
RESIDENTS AND AMERICAN IDEALS
AND I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS MATTER [inaudible]
LACKING [inaudible]
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
[inaudible]
ON THE JERRY ARE [inaudible]
THIS CARILLO.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF THE
LATINO CAUCUS TO SUPPORT JOINT
RESOLUTION SIXTEEN BY THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM SANTA CLARITA.
THE MISGUIDED DECISION TO AND
TEMPORARY PROTECTED STATUS FOR
VARIOUS COUNTRIES HAS EXPOSED
THE TPS MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY
TO POTENTIAL.
DEPORTATIONS FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN DECADES OUR STATE IS HOME TO
OVER FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND TPS
RECIPIENTS MANY OF WHICH RESIDE.
IN MY DISTRICT AND THE LARGER
LOS ANGELES AREA.
MANY TPS RECIPIENTS ARE ALSO
PARENTS OF CHILDREN WHO ARE
AMERICAN CITIZENS IF THEIR
PARENTS ARE FORCED TO LEAVE THE
COUNTRY THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES.
WILL BE POTENTIALLY RIPPED APART
AND THEIR CHILDREN LEFT WITH
LEFT BEHIND WITHOUT MANY
OPTIONS.
BEAST DEPORTATIONS WILL COST OUR
STATE THOUSANDS OF LAW ABIDING
HARDWORKING RESIDENTS WHO PAY
TAXES AND CONTRIBUTE MILLIONS.
TO OUR ECONOMY.
TPS RECIPIENTS PARTICIPATE IN
THE LABOR FORCE THAT AVERAGE
RATES OF 85% WELL ABOVE THE U.
S. POPULATION OF 63%.
I COMMEND OUR REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA CLARITA AND
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM
PALMDALE FOR RECOGNIZING THE
CRISIS CREATED BY THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION'S DECISION.
AND FOR SUPPORTING THE
BIPARTISAN CALLS FOR LEGAL
PATHWAY FORWARD THINK YOU AND I
URGE YOUR AYE AYE VOTE ON THIS
RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISS CREEL
[inaudible]
SEEING NO [inaudible]
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
[inaudible]
OR DEBATE.
MISTER LACKEY YOU MAY CLOSE HAVE
YOU WISH AND WHAT YOU LIKE CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
YES CERTAINLY I WENT OUT FOR THE
FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS AND WOULD ASK YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
LACKEY WITH THAT CORPORAL THE
ROLE.
CO AUTHORS ON THE SJ ARE CO
AUTHORS AND WE ARE.
SIXTEEN CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE THERE ARE FIFTY NINE
CO AUTHORS ADDED.
SILVESTRI OUR CIVIL TAKE A ROLL
CALL VOTE THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE I AM.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHICH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS WHO WISH TO VOTE
[inaudible]
KIRK WELL.
CLOSER ON TIE ABOUT ICE FIFTY
NINE NO.
ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS AND FILE ORDER.
WE ARE FILE ITEM THIRTY S. B.
TEN FIFTY THREE THIS IS ON THE
SENATE.
THIRD READING FILE.
CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL TEN FIFTY THREE BY
SENATOR BELL AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO GOVERNMENT CLAIMS
[inaudible]
MS RACE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I PRESENT TO S. B. TEN FIFTY
THREE WHICH IS THE CLARIFICATION
OF EXISTING LAW THAT PROTECTS
THE CIVIL.
LEGAL RIGHTS OF THOSE INJURED
THROUGH CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ABUSE.
THE GOVERNMENT TORT CLAIMS ACT
REQUIRES CLAIMS RELATED TO DEATH
OR INJURY BE PRESENTED NO LATER
THAN SIX MONTHS AFTER THE
INCIDENT OCCURRED.
THE LEGISLATURE KNOWLEDGE IT IS
UNREASONABLE TO EXPECT A CLAIM
WILL ALWAYS BE FILED WITHIN SIX
MONTHS OF INACTIVE ABUSE.
IN TWO THOUSAND NINE S. B. SIX
FORTY WAS CHAPTER.
EXEMPTING CASES OF CHILDHOOD
SEXUAL ABUSE FROM THE TORT
CLAIMS PROCESS.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE HAVE BEEN
CASES HANDLED IN WAYS THAT WERE
NOT THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE.
THIS BILL IS A CLARIFICATION OF
EXISTING LAW.
CLOSE UNINTENDED THE LOOPHOLES
IN CODE THAT HAVE LED TO CHILD
ABUSE CASES BEING DISMISSED.
THE BILL HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
A PORT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THINKING HIS RENTS SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CARCLUB THE ROLL-ON.
IT IS OUR VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE.
CLERK WELL CLOSE A ROLLING TIME.
EYES.
SEVENTY THREE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS RETAIN ON
FILE ITEMS.
THIRTY ONE THREE THIRTY FIVE
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER. THIRTY SIX S. B.
[inaudible]
NINE FOURTEEN CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL NINE FOURTEEN BY
SENATOR DODD AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC CONTRACTS
[inaudible]
MISTER GRAYSON.
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY
AND PRESENTING S. B. NINE
FOURTEEN WHICH WOULD AUTHORIZE
COUNTIES TO DELIVER PROJECTS
USING THE CONSTRUCTION MANAGER
AT RISK OR SEA MAR CONTRACTING
METHOD.
A SEA MAR CONTRACTORS A
COMPETITIVELY PROCURED CONTRACT
FOR A PROJECT THAT GUARANTEES
THE COST OF THE PROJECT AND
FURNISHES CONSTRUCTION
MANAGEMENT SERVICES.
PROJECTS THAT HAVE MULTIPLE
PHASES LYNN THEMSELVES TO THIS
METHOD.
BECAUSE THE DESIGN AND
CONSTRUCTION OF DIFFERENT
ASPECTS OF THE PROJECT CAN OCCUR
AT DIFFERENT TIMES LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE AUTHORIZED SEA MAR
TO BE USED FOR BUILDING
PROJECTS.
AND THAT PROPOSAL PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY WITH BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AUTHORIZING THIS METHOD
OF PROCUREMENT WILL PROVIDE
COUNTIES WITH THE NECESSARY
TOOL.
TO DELIVER FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE
OF PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS ENSURE HIGH QUALITY
CONSTRUCTION AT A GUARANTEED
PRICE REDUCE PUBLIC SECTOR
LIABILITY AND ENSURE MORE TIMELY
COMPETITION OR COMPLETION.
OF PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS SO S.
B. NINE FOURTEEN GRANTS COUNTIES
THE FLEXIBILITY TO BUILD
PROJECTS THAT THEY NEED IN THE
MOST EFFICIENT MANNER POSSIBLE.
WITH WHICH TRANSLATES INTO
SAVINGS FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND TAXPAYERS ALIKE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIGHT.
HE WAS GRAYSON.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
THE SAD ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DECIDED THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE AROUND TIED ABOUT AYE AYES
FIFTY FIVE KNOWS.
FIVE THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING.
TO MOVE TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
[inaudible]
SO TRY MEMBERS HAD SKIPPED
MISTER GIPSON MISTER GIBSON DOES
HAVE AN ITEM.
ON THE FILE.
MISTER GIBSON'S ITEM IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY THREE AS ACR ONE NINETY
SIX CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE EIGHTY SIX ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON AND OTHERS BELTED HIV
TESTING DAY.
MISTER GIPSON EMAIL.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AS THE
CHAIRPERSON AS THE CHAIR OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON INFECTIOUS
DISEASES I RISE TO PRESENT.
OF ACR ONE NINETY SIX WHICH WERE
PROCLAIMS JUNE TWENTY SEVENTH AS
HIV TESTING DAY.
AS SOMEONE WHO HAS BEEN ACTIVE
IN HIV AIDS ISSUES FOR MANY
YEARS.
I HAVE SEEN THE AFFECT OF HIV
AIDS EXPRESSLY AROUND THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN LATINO
COMMUNITY --
TWO DAYS AGO MY GODSON'S MOTHER.
WHAT IS CELEBRATING HER
BIRTHDAY?
TODAY'S MY BIRTHDAY [inaudible]
MY GODSON'S.
FATHER'S BIRTHDAY THE TWENTY
SIXTH OF JUNE.
ALL THREE OF US GREW UP IN
CHURCH TOGETHER.
BUT BOTH THE MOTHER AND FATHER
DIED OF AIDS.
AND SO THIS IS VERY PERSONAL FOR
ME.
AND SO THE SO THESE POPULATIONS
ARE IMPACTED.
BUT THE LACK OF ACCESS TO
SERVICES.
AND HAVING DISPROPORTIONATELY
HIGH NEW INFECTIOUS RATES AND
THAT CAN AMERICA THAT THE
COMMUNITY.
THIS RESOLUTION SEEK TO RAISE
THE AWARENESS. TO ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE TO GET A ROUTINE TEST.
FOR HIV AND KNOW YOUR STATUS.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK AND I
BOTH THE FIRST ROW GLOBAL
COAUTHORS.
THANK MISS GIPSON.
IS WATER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ON MY RISE AS THE JOINT
AUTHORS THE VCR ONE NINETY SIX
MEASURE TO RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF GETTING TESTED FOR
HIV.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS LIVE WITH HIV AIDS
TODAY YET ONLY ONE ANTENNAS
AWARE OF THEIR STATUS.
WE NEED TO ENCOURAGE MORE
CALIFORNIANS TO GET THE FACTS
AND LEARN THEIR STATUS AS WELL
AS ON THE STAND SOME OF THE
PREVENTIVE MEASURES THAT CAN BE.
UTILIZED ACCORDING INCLUDING
PREP [inaudible]
AND PAT.
OF THE PROTOCOLS GETTING CONTROL
OF HIV EARLY STAYING ON
MEDICATIONS IS THE BEST WAY TO
STABILIZE THIS DISEASE AND
REDUCE VIRAL TRANSMISSIONS.
WERE TRYING TO GET THE ZERO IN
OUR STATE HIRED AYE VOTE.
THANK MISS WALDRON.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
MISTER GIBSON WOULD LIKE CO
AUTHORS ON THE FIRST ROLE.
WITH THAT CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON AUTHORS.
ON THE C. ARE CO AUTHORS ACR.
ONE NINETY SIX THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE THERE SEVENTY
THREE CO AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY.
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE ADAM
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE AT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
MISTER CALDERON FREE EMOTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
TO SEE I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO US ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY TO PRINT A
LETTER IN THE JOURNAL.
RELATING TO THE RECENT ACTIONS
OF THE JOINT RULES COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THAT REQUEST WAS GRANTED.
AND NOW MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
GO TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
DOES ANY MEMBER WHICH REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND A
CONSENT CALENDAR.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN THIRTY NINE
BY SENATOR MORALE AND ACTUALLY
TO REAL PROPERTY.
WITHOUT THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTED TO SARAH
VOTE THIS IS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
THIS IS CONSENT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE OF A ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE YOUR OWN TIED
BUT I SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
AND THE CLERK WILL READ THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SENATE BILL NINE TWENTY FIVE I
SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO SENATE
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE I SEVENTY
TWO NO ZERO CYNICAL FIFTEEN OF
SEVEN I SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO AND
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION.
TWENTY FIVE I SEVENTY TWO NO.
ZERO MEMBERS WE ARE.
WE MOVE TO ANNOUNCEMENTS AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY HOWEVER
QUORUM CALL IS IN PLACE WE ARE
AWAITING.
ACTION IN THE SENATE.
SO QUORUM CALLS IN PLACE I LIKE
TO CALL ON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
[inaudible]
JONES SAWYER. FOR YOUR SPECIAL
ANNOUNCEMENT MISTER JONES SAWYER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBERS BLOOM
BURKE GIPSON CRISTINA GARCIA
MULLIN REYES STONE AND SENATOR
SKINNER AND MYSELF I LIKE TO
INVITE MEMBERS AND THEIR STAFF
TO ATTEND.
THE ANNUAL SUMMER WHITE SUIT DAY
RECEPTION TODAY FROM FIVE TO SIX
PM ON THE SECOND FLOOR PATIO
ROOM.
TWO ONE ONE SEVEN THEY ALSO LIKE
TO MEMBERS THAT ARE WEARING
WHITE TODAY.
TO YOU TAKE A FOR PHOTO UPON
ADJOURNMENT.
SESSION TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER.
STAYING WITH ANNOUNCEMENTS
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
TUESDAY JUNE TWENTY SIX CHECK IN
SESSION.
WEDNESDAY JUNE TWENTY SEVENTH
CHECK IN SESSION AND THURSDAY
JUNE TWENTY EIGHTH.
THE FLOOR SESSION IS AT NINE AM.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON IN GERMANY MEMORY.
MEMBERS OUT ASK YOU PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS.
IF YOU MUST HAVE A CONVERSATION
PLEASE TAKE IT OFF OF THE GREEN
CARPET.
WE ARE AT A ITEMS DR EGGMAN.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
A THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS IT IS WITH GREAT SADNESS
THAT I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN IN
THE MEMORY OF THREE STOCK TONY
JONES JOE LOWER.
GINA'S YANG AND THEIR FIVE YEAR
OLD DAUGHTER CAYLEE MORE.
MEMBERS MOTHER'S DAY SHOULD BE A
HAPPY DAY.
BUT ON MOTHER'S DAY AND STOCKTON
THIS YEAR.
IN THE SIERRA VISTA HOUSING
PROJECT.
A DRIVE BY KICK OCCURRED AND
WHILE FAMILY WAS CELEBRATING
MOTHER'S DAY WITH THEIR FAMILY
AND LOVED ONES.
SOMEONE CAME BY AND FIRED INTO
THE APARTMENT AND ENDED UP
KILLING JOE.
HIS WIFE GINA AND THEIR FIVE
YEAR OLD DAUGHTER [inaudible]
KALEY MORE.
THIS SENSELESS KILLING HAS
RESULTED IN IMMENSE SORROW IN
THE MONK COMMUNITY.
IN THE CITY OF STOCKTON.
JOE WAS A LOVING FATHER HUSBAND
BROTHER.
THE TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
GRADUATE OF FRANKLIN HIGH
SCHOOL.
DEBATED YMCA WAS INVOLVED AND
ACTIVE WITH HIS LOVING FAMILY.
DO YOU KNOW ALSO GRETA FROM
FRANKLIN HIGH SCHOOL AND IS
REMEMBERED AS A NURTURING MOTHER
WIFE DAUGHTER SISTER AND FRIEND.
LITTLE KAELIN WAS THE FOCUS OF
TREMENDOUS LOVE BY HER PARENTS
HER EXTENDED FAMILY.
EXHIBITED ARE AN OUTGOING
PERSONALITY.
WANT TO BE A POLICE OFFICER.
SPECIAL FONDNESS FOR ANIMALS
ESPECIALLY HORSES AND DOGS.
TODAY WE HONOR THOSE LIVES.
AND MEMBERS ONLY THINK ABOUT
SENSELESS KILLINGS THAT OCCUR.
AND I THINK WE NEED TO CONTINUE
TO REACH OUT TO ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES TO REPORT THINGS
THAT THEY SEE.
REMAINING SILENT WHEN SENSELESS
KILLINGS OCCURS MAKES NOBODY A
HERO MIXED NOBODY TOUGH.
FAMILIES NEED TO HAVE RESOLVED
AND AND KNOW WHAT HAS HAPPENED
NO.
PEOPLE ARE LEFT THINKING WHY.
AND I THINK WE ALL ARE STRUCK
WITH THAT.
AND WHY AS WE THINK ABOUT THE
FAMILIES IMPACTED BY THAT KIND
OF SENSELESS TRAGEDY.
IT'S INCUMBENT UPON ALL OF US I
THINK TO WORK WITH AS MUCH.
WITH OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT.
COMMUNITIES AND OUR COMMUNITIES
ALTOGETHER TO BE ABLE TO BUILD
THE KIND OF TRUST THAT WE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO STOP THIS KIND OF
VIOLENCE BEFORE IT OCCURS.
SO PLEASE JOIN ME MEMBERS IN
ADJOURNING IN MEMORY OF OF THIS
FAMILY.
AND OF THIS COMMUNITY.
AND LET US ALL RECOMMIT. TO WORK
ON REDUCING VIOLENCE.
AND THE AMOUNT OF GUNS THAT ARE
ON OUR STREETS.
SO THAT WE CAN ALL LIVE IN PEACE
THINK.
THANK YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN.
MR THURMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR ME TO ASK REAR A GERMAN A
MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
--
SADLY I RISE TO ASK THAT THIS
BODY ADJOURNED IN MEMORY.
OFFER THOMAS TOM BEAT MALARKEY.
OF WHO WAS A CONSTITUENT AND A
FRIEND WHO LIVED IN RICHMOND --
TOM.
THE FIVE YEARS OLD.
AND HE LOST HIS LIFE.
ON A SKI TRIP.
THE BEAR VALLEY SKI RESORT
[inaudible]
I HE WENT MISSING.
ON MARCH FOURTEENTH.
AND WAS FOUND TWO MONTHS LATER.
ON MAY THE FOURTEEN TOM.
IS KNOWN FOR HIS LOVE OF FAMILY.
S. VOLUNTEERISM IN THE
COMMUNITY.
STRONG CATHOLIC FAITH.
LEADERSHIP IN HIS UNION.
HIS INFECTIOUS SPIRIT IN HIS
LOVE.
OF THE OUTDOORS.
TOM'S BORN IN OAKLYN.
JULY NINTH NINETEEN FIFTY TWO HE
GREW UP IN ALBANY HE GREW UP.
IN ALBANY ATTENDING CORNELL
SCHOOL THE SCHOOL OF THE
MADELEINE.
HE GRADUATED FROM ST MARY'S HIGH
SCHOOL IN BERKELEY.
AFTER HIGH SCHOOL TOM BECAME AN
APPRENTICE ELECTRICIAN.
WITH THE INTERNATIONAL
BROTHERHOOD OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS LOCAL.
FIVE NINE FIVE THAT
APPRENTICESHIP MORPHED INTO A
FORTY FIVE YEAR CAREER FOR TOM
--
AND THE LAST.
SEVEN AS HIS BUSINESS MANAGER
FOR LOCAL.
FIVE NINE FIVE TOM WAS AN
ADVOCATE FOR FAIR LIVING WAGES.
STERN ABOUT ENVIRONMENTAL CAUSES
IS SERVED ON THE ALAMEDA LABOR
COUNCIL.
AND THE I B. E. W. FIVE NINE
FIVE HEALTH AND WELFARE BOARD.
I TOM IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE OF
THIRTY SIX YEARS JANE DRUMMOND
MALARKEY.
HIS CHILDREN ELIZABETH WHO ARE
MATTHEW MALARKEY.
AND FOUR BEAUTIFUL
GRANDCHILDREN.
WHEN TOM RETIRED A FEW YEARS
AGO?
HE COMMITTED HIMSELF THE THE
THING THAT HE'S BEEN COMMITTED
TO HIS WHOLE LIFE.
IT'S FAMILY YOU RUN INTO TOM ON
THE TRAIN OR IN THE COMMUNITY.
AND TOM ALWAYS HAD A SMILE OR
KIND WORD OR PAT ON THE BACK.
YOU NEVER COMPLAIN.
HE WAS ALWAYS THERE TO HELP.
IS ALWAYS A GOOD NEIGHBOR AND A
GOOD FRIEND.
COLLEAGUES I ASK THAT WE KEEP
THEM LUCKY FAMILY AND THEIR
FRIENDS AND HIS BROTHERS AND
SISTERS IN LABOR IN OUR THOUGHTS
AND PRAYERS AND I ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN.
IN THE MEMORY OF TOM MALARKEY.
THANK YOU MISTER THURMAN.
MEMBERS PLEASE READ THE NAMES OF
THE DEATHS REPRINT OF INTERNAL
REQUEST RETURNING MEMORY WILL BE
DEEMED READ.
AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
MEMBERS QUORUM CALL IS STILL IN
PLACE
.
MEMBERS MAY HAVE YOUR ATTENTION.
I'M GOING TO RECOGNIZE DOCTOR
EGGMAN. FOR AN INTRODUCTION
RELATIVE TO HER GERMAN IN
MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE THE RETENTION TO
DOCTOR EGGMAN THINK YOU MEMBERS
OF FAMILIES OUT OF THE ROOM AND
I DID THE GERMAN IN MEMORY BUT
I'D LIKE.
TO RECOGNIZE THE LOWER FAMILY UP
IN THE GALLERY --
WHO LOST THEIR SON OF THEIR
DAUGHTER IN LAW AND THEIR
GRANDSON AND I QUE LOWER BOND
WORKS -- DIE
HERE IN THE CAPITAL COMMUNITY A
SO WITH THEIR LOSS IS OUR LOSS
AND PLEASE MEMBERS EXTEND TO
THEM ALL OR PART CONDOLENCES FOR
THEIR LOSS
.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
BRIEF ANNOUNCEMENT A REMINDER
THAT THE ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE WILL BE MEETING UPON
ADJOURNMENT OF SESSION.
IN ROOM FORTY TO GO TO THAT'S
ASSEMBLY TRANS AND ROOM FORTY
TWO A TWO UPON ADJOURNMENT
[inaudible]
WE ARE IN POSSESSION OF AB.
EIGHTEEN TWENTY SEVEN MEMBERS
THIS IS.
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE.
MEMBERS RADIO MOTION FIRST AND
THEN TAKE UP THE REMAINING ITEM
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
EIGHTEEN TWENTY SEVEN AS AT THE
DESK I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE SIXTY
THREE AND SEVENTY SEVEN TO TAKE
UP THE BILL WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE FOR THE PURPOSE OF CAN.
MISS WALDRON WE OPPOSE THE WAR.
MISS WALDRON IS WITHHOLDING APPS
UNANIMOUS CONSENT ON THE RULES
SUSPENSION MISTER CALDERON MOVES
MISTER BONTA SECONDS MEMBERS
THIS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE ON
SUSPENSION OF THE RULES CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
MISS WALDRON AND NO MISTER
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR IN AYE
AND MISS WALDRON AND NO. TO
PROCEDURAL VOTE.
TAKES FORTY ONE THIS IS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSER ALL.
UNTIL I VOTE EYES.
FIFTY ONE KNOWS TWENTY THE RULES
ARE SUSPENDED.
AND NOW WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE.
WE WE'LL BE TAKING UP A. B..
EIGHTEEN TWENTY SEVEN THE
CARBURETOR.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
AND ACTUALLY THE HOUSING MAKING
PREPARATION THEREFORE IT
DECLINED URGENCY THERE UP TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
MISTER TANG YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
EIGHTEEN TWENTY SEVEN PROVIDES.
FOR SUBMISSION THE NO PLACE LIKE
HOME PROGRAM TO THE VOTERS.
ON THE NOVEMBER SIXTH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN STATEWIDE GENERAL
ELECTION.
THE BILL DECLARES ANNOUNCED
VOTERS TO CLARIFY THEIR
INTENTION THAT THE BONTA CAN
MOVE FORWARD AND HELPED
CONSTRUCT.
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING THAT WAS AN
ISSUE THAT WE'VE BEEN VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE LAST FEW YEARS
IN THE BUDGET.
THIS IS TO ASK FOR THE VOTERS
RATIFICATION RIGHT ABOUT
EDUCATION OF THAT.
CLARIFICATION INSIST IN
NOVEMBER.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FIVE THE FAMOUS TAKE A MEASURE
OBERNOLTE OR RECOMMEND MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN TWENTY SEVEN I THINK
IT'S VERY APPROPRIATE TO PUT THE
NO PLACE LIKE HOME ACT ON THE
BALLOT.
IN NOVEMBER FOR VOTER APPROVAL
THE VOTERS SHOULD BE TRUSTED TO
MAKE THE RIGHT DECISION ON THESE
BONDS AS THEY MAKE THE RIGHT
DECISIONS ON ALL OTHER BONDS AYE
URGENT AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
[inaudible]
OR DEBATE.
CLERK LIBERAL.
MEMBERS VOTE.
THESE ARE ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE IN TYLER.
I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
EYES SIXTY NINE DOES YOUR ON THE
URGENCY I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO ON
THE BILL.
MEMBERS THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN ON A. B..
EIGHTEEN TWENTY SEVEN MEMBERS
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED RETAIN.
ALL MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED
SEEING HER YOU KNOW FOR THE
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER CALDERON MOVES MS RUBIO
SECONDS AT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY JUNE
[inaudible]
TWENTY EIGHT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
THURSDAY.
JUNE TWENTY EIGHTH AT NINE AM.
AND THE QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED